he's an Irish singing Powerhouse his
name is Dermot Kennedy
[Music]
[Music]
now that's Mr Kennedy performing his hit
song it's called Paradise with Medusa
the song has more than one more than 550
million streams not 100
550 million streams on Spotify wow last
month Kennedy released his highly
anticipated new album is called sonder
Jan Crawford sits down with him at
Hartley's Irish Pub right here in New
York City on the album's release day
they talked about the music as meteoric
rise and where it all began
so kiss me the way
that you were
if we die tonight if we die tonight
you never know where singer Dermot
Kennedy may show up so when the night
feels like forever in a park in San
Diego California if you ever leave a
whole
house
Sweden
blistering cold under a bridge in
Brooklyn New York
[Music]
even as Kennedy sells out stadiums
worldwide he still finds time to go back
to his roots street performing let this
Knight invade my lungs you're all I
wanna breathe 16 years old he like sat
down and opened up your cake yeah yeah
yeah it wasn't as nice as this the case
or the guitar but yeah that was the
first time I went and did it and it was
very intimidating situation but it put
me in a good spot you know to play the
people
skiing is very much a part of Kennedy's
path
as a teenager in Dublin it gave him the
courage to perform
foreign
[Music]
it's a remarkable Journey for someone
who says he was painfully shy as a kid I
think I didn't speak at all so my best
example that I can give is that we would
have all the lockers set out and
obviously the idea being in the morning
you get the books you need put them in
your bag and then you go back put them
back grab whatever you need for me I
would go around with like every book I
needed for the whole day because I just
did not want the social situation of
being at the lockers like I after every
class have to see more good and then you
wouldn't know who'd be there and you
would know what could happen yeah I
hated it I just was Incognito for six
years now you're still standing on
street corners with hundreds of people
right there in your space or you're
performing in front of 20 000 people on
stage I know they like me though
you know that's your fans
[Music]
now 30 Kennedy is as comfortable on a
street corner as he is in stadiums
before tens of thousands
I feel a bit more accomplished a bit
more established feel more confident in
who I am
[Music]
under it took him three years to make
see your shape under gold street lights
but every time I'm close you move what's
a Saunder Saunder is the awareness and
the realization that everybody is living
life as Vivid and complex as your own I
guess ultimately it's empathy right that
idea of treat everybody with kindness
because you don't know what they're
going through
[Music]
this is made up of 11 emotional songs
including Kennedy's single better days
the rain it ain't permanent released
during the pandemic soon we'll be
dancing in the Sun
we'll be dancing in the sun I think the
first time we played it
was at a festival in Glasgow
it was all this stuff of like I know
you've been hurting
[Music]
and everything felt so appropriate and
kind of Apt for what people have been
through and I could see how happy people
were and I was just like ah this song is
about covert now this is what this is
well it was just right song in the
moment yeah yeah
[Applause]
Kennedy has long been known for his
vulnerable lyrics and unique music style
and if only you could see yourself in my
eyes a mix of folks
[Music]
and Hip Hop if love had come to me I
wouldn't recognize one of the things
that people really love about your music
is your lyrics
[Music]
and I read one time that you said
trying to make people feel something
anything
I've never known a purpose like it if I
hear a piece of music that moves me or
if I go to a show where I can't believe
that these certain frequencies and words
make my body feel that way I just I want
to do that to people it's an incredible
privilege and to kind of be the vehicle
to make someone feel not even better but
just feel something you know so um it's
an honor for me to do that
still Kennedy never forgets where he
started on Dublin's Grafton Street
[Applause]
but it looks a little different when he
shows up there now but once upon a time
[Music]
one thing I'm going out of
that out of respect Once Upon a Time
[Music]
he might think a day is the worst day in
the world but like things will improve
you know and I think that exists in a
lot of my music
yeah I mean there's always like you can
go on there will be better days
so to speak together
for CBS mornings I'm Jan Crawford in
Brooklyn New York but it is a common
if no one told you
[Music]
beautiful voice I learned in the word
Saunder Saunder and the meaning of it is
very important right realizing everyone
else has a vivid and complex life and is
living it just like you are I also love
the message of Hope in his music you
know no matter how bad you think it is
it will get better yeah it will be the
light